et on reste en amérique latine au brésil
le président jacques bolson araud a
nommé carlos alberto des côtes est lié
au ministère de l'éducation
une nomination qui survient alors que sa
gestion du pays
elle suscite toujours de nombreuses
polémiques le style bol sauna ou est
ainsi décrypté dans une tribune publiée
dans le journal le monde selon la
politiste mélanie albarel le bol sonar
isme se rapproche des autres régimes
populiste et inhibe héros mais conserve
des spécificités dans ses pratiques
politiques
il mobilise des ressorts
caractéristiques d'une grande partie des
leaders populistes ou i libéraux au
pouvoir dans le monde
ces mécanismes s'inscrivent en outre
dans la continuité de logique déjà
présente au brésil avant la crise
sanitaire qui ont conduit à la
militarisation du pouvoir et à des
glissements successifs vers un régime
autoritaire et répressif mais pour en
parler nous sommes avec jean jacques
fontaine journaliste et spécialiste du
brésil
bonjour jean jacques ont-elles merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors le président à brésilien qui
poursuit sa lutte face aux
contre-pouvoirs l'opposition est elle
assez organisés pour faire vaciller
wolson araud alors non et c'est bien le
le fond du problème c'est à dire que
l'opposition aujourd'hui n'arrive pas à
se structurer ou à s'unir pour faire
face à bolton 0 alors que wilson à roux
n'est pas majoritaire dans le pays on
peut pas parler d'un bol sauna risma
tant que tel il y à lui il y à sa
famille il y à son gourou à la volée car
valeo quête aux états unis et puis il y
a à peu près 30% des électeurs qui le
soutiennent mais
il suffit pour pour tenir face rovit qui
est de l'autre côté alors de l'épidémie
de coronavirus ball sonar ou minimisant
l'ampleur de cette crise en prévision
l'économie du pays sur l'aspect
sanitaire
comment cette gestion est elle perçue au
brésil alors savait pas par qui il ya
évidemment les soutiennent molson arrow
qui appuie son son action notamment du
côté des lieder des églises évangélistes
il y a aussi dans la population pauvre
un certain nombre de personnes qui
soutiennent sa politique dans la mesure
où ils redistribuent un peu d excuser
moi des aides d'état aux plus pauvres
et puis il y a le reste au fond la
grande majorité de la population qui est
un peu amorphe
face à cette situation ne le soutient
pas le critiquent régulièrement il ya
des concerts de casseroles sur les
balcons chaque fois que commence le
journal télévisé pour pour critiquer vol
sonar ou mais ça va pas beaucoup plus
loin
alors on l'a dit un plus de 55000
personnes sont décédées au brésil à
cause de l'épidémie de coronavirus est
ce qu'aujourd'hui jr ball sonar ou et
son gouvernement ont pris conscience de
ce qu'était cette épidémie de
coronavirus et est-ce que son
gouvernement justement mais on met en
place les choses pour lutter contre
l'épidémie
lui non son gouvernement en partie mais
il faut pas oublier que le brésil est un
pays fédéral
ça veut dire que au niveau de la santé
notamment le rôle des différents états
est très important et selon les états
les gouverneurs sont plus ou moins
impliqués dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus ce qui fait qu'on peut ni
parler d'une politique d'ensemble pour
le pays ni parler d'une politique
générale de lutte contre le virus
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des moments où
l'épidémie se développe dans certaines
parties du pays puis régresse se
développe dans d'autres ce qui est sûr
en tout cas c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
politique cohérente et que le virus
continue à augmenter à circuler de plus
en plus au brésil alors on l'a dit aussi
également le pouvoir de germolles sun
araw de plus en plus contesté on se
souvient de ces manifestations la
semaine dernière du côté de brasilia où
des pro et anti vol sonar au se sont
fait face pendant plusieurs minutes
est ce que c'est aujourd'hui le symbole
d'une fracture sociale profonde de voir
qu'en pleine épidémie meurtrière
il y a toujours une opposition politique
divisée en deux camps bien distincts
alors c'est en tout cas une fracture
politique très claire et que j'ai un bon
sonar ou ne cherche pas à résorber au
contraire ce n'est pas un président qui
gouverne pour l'ensemble des brésiliens
c'est un président qui gouverne pour ces
trous à lui donc effectivement à la
maille même manière que donald trump aux
états unis ils alimentent cette fracture
politique qui se traduit dans la
population mais faut pas oublier que la
population elle même est assez
désarçonné parce qu'elles sont aussi
d'un gouvernement du pays des contes et
terriblement marqué par pas par la
corruption à l'époque
donc c'est plus le désarroi qu'autre
chose je dirais alors ball sonar haut et
de plus en plus contesté on le disait
certains demandent même une destitution
du président brésilien
il est contestée notamment par le
parlement mais aussi par le tribunal
suprême très rapidement pour conclure
que petit lui arriver alors moi je
dirais à court terme rien parce que les
forces d'opposition s'annulent que les
raisons qui pourraient être avancées
pour sa destitution ne sont pas
suffisants pour
recueillir une grande majorité au
congrès donc en fait à mon avis il va
rien se passer dans l'immédiat en tout
cas par rapport à paulson araud merci
beaucoup jean jacques fontaine d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste du brésil merci beaucoup
merci